estos vaqueros se reúnen para hablar de
sus sentimientos
uno de los suyos murió de una sobredosis
en 2021 ahora han creado un espacio para
que ninguno se quede sin compartir sus
luchas adicciones o problemas de salud
mental en una comunidad que tiene
principalmente tradiciones machistas y
en donde las emociones siempre han
quedado en un segundo plano
se supone que los vaqueros son duros
hemos nacido y crecido para ser
independientes y no depender de nadie y
muchas de las cosas que hacemos son por
nuestra cuenta así que no tenemos esa
capacidad de comunicación para ir a otro
sitio y hablar y compartir nuestras
emociones y creo que muchos de nosotros
luchamos con eso
con vastas llanuras y montañas rocosas
wyoming y es el último bastión del oeste
de eeuu es el estado con la población
más baja del país con menos de 600.000
habitantes y su superficie representa el
doble de un país como grecia a
diferencia de las grandes ciudades no
cuentan con un sistema sólido para
atender adecuadamente los problemas de
salud mental
debido a la singularidad de wyoming ya
no tenemos los recursos que se
encuentran en otros estados no tenemos
un grupo masivo de proveedores de salud
mental en todo el estado y profesionales
para el tratamiento de los trastornos
por uso de sustancias
con cerca de 670 miembros en facebook la
iniciativa no más sillas vacías espera
desde la experiencia y el diálogo evitar
que muchas personas busquen una solución
a problemas en el suicidio se financian
con las donaciones de sus seguidores y
esperan que su causa resuene en todo el
país